please
okay for people joining this live stream
we are reviewing some wolfram language
functionality
this is getting in just under the wire
before i
go off and do my extreme professoring
activity for the year with our various
summer programs
um probably the last design review uh
before
that all kicks off on monday there'll be
a bunch of live streams related to that
for people who are interested
okay our agenda here is to look at
the um uh functions
uh date setter and time setter is that
correct
that is correct
okay let's see what this looks like and
do we have a cloud story for this and we
have cloud people here
uh you know i don't know if we have
cloud people or not but
but this is you know we have some months
until
you know these this would go into a
release so we have we have
time to uh you know to work out the
cloud story
okay all right here goes
date sata oops so uh the uh
sorry right now these all live in a
special context so
if you want to uh append uh uh
it's the context is called date and time
you can see it in the first example
uh so if you want to append
you know date and time dear to your
dollar context path
okay
okay so
is this this is
let's remind my ourselves what are some
other set of things
okay so let's say color setter
okay so there's that it then pops up
it then selects something
and then becomes the thing it is so to
speak
so
oh no that's wrong isn't it what's wrong
with it
i have to say setting of that is that
correct
right
okay all right also fine so then
this is a rather boring setup um
sure yeah why is the year not selectable
i mean
you know um i don't understand why
that's any less i mean why not have that
be a
a chugger as well i mean since most
likely you're not going very many years
away
uh yeah well it's i think that's a
reasonable question which i hadn't
thought of i guess the main thing is you
know just picking sort of a default
range of years um
which you know i don't know but i meant
to go okay how do i make an actual
calendar
uh so uh choose
uh this is something that is still a bit
of a work in progress right now you can
just say appearance
arrow calendar but the thing that comes
up doesn't have
a uh a month or year selector and this
is something that
i asked kevin to fix but the fix didn't
make it in time for
uh uh oh wait oh wait there it is
okay graphic design do we have somebody
from graphic design here
yes hi it's billy okay this looks
terrible so far
yeah billy billy has not seen this so
okay um
so so so he gets no blame for his
present appearance
right i mean
just to give a sense here so in this
why isn't there why aren't these just
arrowy things
so these are a pickup but but this
approach here
i see so this is a forward backward yeah
and this is a picker of any date and
that's just to type in
yes uh with also a forward and backward
i mean i strongly think this should be
the default
this calendar appearance
possibly uh i
like to hear if uh the the
the the time and date people here have
any strong opinions about that
yeah i mean i think it's a trade-off of
whether we want it to look more like a
date object which is what the current
default is
or if we want it to look more like a
sort of scheduler that
you're used to seeing in your calendar
app or what have you i think
probably from a usability perspective it
makes sense to go a little more calendar
focus since that's the interface people
are used to
but there is also a decent case to say
if we want it to be basically
a adjustable date object that the
current behavior is most
closely aligned with the type setting of
data object
i think both are useful for example if
you have to introduce your birthday
the calendar is not that useful
but if you are worrying about nearby
days then it's more useful
sorry wait a minute what are you just
saying the i i'm saying that both have
their uh applications for example if you
have to introduce your birth date
typically you are offered the the the
menu
style not the calendar style because you
don't want to have to
click again again until
um okay what's what are all these
options and things here
um so that's
so yeah you can you can minimize the
window for now
okay um
okay so uh kevin or or someone want to
walk through some of the input forms
that we have
sure so in terms of just uh
the number of arguments this is designed
as a control
but there is the non-dynamic form which
you can put in anything that date object
understands
as a an appropriate date format
that's what the first set of scope
examples is showing
uh it's fully hooked into the new locale
stuff so you can set the locale inside
the date format and
this is all based around what date
object type sets as
so that's what most of the documentation
shows
right this is cool um
graphic design wise this needs some work
i mean you know the the
this for example it's
um i think our beginning is okay
well well certainly certainly the you
know the field
should be you know the field heights
should be evened up
between the different controls if there
is even a different control
but yeah so i agree with that
okay so and i i'm i'm kind of wondering
graphic design wise
you know should we have some separator
line here or something but it can't be a
full separator because we
the whole thing is our beginning
whatever
um
do you get what i'm saying i'm just it's
getting hard to read at this point
now if i if i go here if i say
um
calendar type arrow
let's say jewish what am i gonna get
here
oh my gosh you didn't think that was
going to work did you
well why doesn't it say our beginning
yeah uh because the oh actually um when
you switch to a different calendar type
it's changing the date format sort of
under the hood
so now this is doing at not just the day
granularity
it's now also shifted the date format
which affects the appearance
uh to have the time included as well
i'm sorry that didn't answer my question
this has granularity the default
granularity
is the default is day the first few
scope examples in the documentation
are our granules i know but so is this
this is what this is it's an hour
granularity
this may be an issue in data objective
itself if you change
this input to data object what does it
do
so just date objects of the same string
and option
right so it's probably coming from there
okay so that's a bug exactly it's
something for us
not yeah okay fine
okay and and this is i mean obviously a
lot of the design principles here
are to hue as closely to date object and
not reinvent the wheel as much as
possible
right clearly for a calendar type
control we have to do
some reinvention but uh okay uh
yeah so this appearance option
how does that follow or not follow date
string or date um
it mostly follows the same format as
date format so you can provide a list of
strings
but there's a bit of extra flair to it
which you can see in the appearance
documentation option
in on this page for example if you have
uh
say a control so any granularity
like month year etc automatically is
interpreted as a control
and you can do arrow goes to none to
suppress a control if you just want to
see the dynamic string
and then you can also choose the control
by having a go arrow to
say pop-up menu
and how does that agree with our date
format up
it agrees almost entirely with the date
format setup except for the addition of
these rules
that i've uh included okay
can anybody else comment on that
yeah i mean it it's the same element
names and same
ordering principle that we have in date
format um like
kevin said i think the main difference
here is just that
because it is a control there are some
additional aspects of manipulating the
appearance that
controls typically have so i think
that's why there's the
slightly but essentially we have this
this if you wanted to have the
the word year in this
how would you do it is there uh
there currently is not a verbatim i have
not implemented that
so there probably should be what is it
in date format
how do you want to in date format how do
i say
give me the state where the actual word
year is in there
do you understand the question uh i i'm
not aware how to do that
yeah we don't have a literal
um verbatim for the expression
in date string because all
basically the string names are keys it's
it's the same
elements that we use in where are the
where are the uh date string has the
full list of them it's there
for why isn't it in date format
we have some of it but um we should have
all of it
it's gonna have to go indirect to
another piece of document
so i mean i mean this yeah this this
goes to other conversations we've had
about
you know if we want to duplicate these
kinds of things
multiple pages how to keep them in sync
i know
we need they need tagging we've talked
about that yeah so date string and date
value have the full list there
date format doesn't but we can certainly
move it over and
try and work on the tagging system for
it
all right so we need a mechanism
so that you can actually have the word
year
in the date string right so if it's not
i mean typically when it's done there
you have some delimiter also so if it's
a string that's year space it will
appear literally as year
but you're right that there probably
should be some way of specifying it
without having to
add white space or something attack yeah
it's it's
definitely a hack um i mean i think
verbatim would certainly be
one method for adding that in
verbatim is not holdable is it
i don't think it is i think no it's not
no okay so it'll be fine i mean so then
we can document that and you can say
um you can say you can use verbatim on
any string you want
other than the strings that actually
represent elements
named elements right yeah okay
yeah it's reminiscent of using the
symbol key
to to wrap around a key for an
association
yep okay
okay let's take a look um
yeah um
various people are commenting this is
ugly graphic design yes this is not yet
graphically designed
um um
okay there's a comment from ethan here
on a live stream is there a way to
restrict or highlight the allowed
dates to choose from that's a good
question
yes there is um again you have to use
the appearance option
but the right hand side of any of the
granularities you can use a pure
function and so you can make the control
whatever you want including restricting
the range of dates so in the appearance
option here in the documentation if you
scroll down a bit
you'll see an example that uses a pure
function
to actually to literally restrict the
dates
okay i'm not sure i'm convinced about
this because i mean we already have this
notion of restricted
right which we use in the case of form
functions
you know what i'm saying and that's
i don't understand this i'm sorry i
don't understand this no you can't put
in
any kind of random crud on the right
hand side here
you know it's a pop-up menu okay that's
the appearance of the thing
great we can have that but you can't
just sort of throw in
i mean how do you know what you're
supposed to do with it i mean you just
have a table you say
if it's a pop-up menu do this if it's
whatever do that but what if you have
some
styling of the pop-up menu that makes it
a pure function
what do you do then oh as if if year
arrow
pure function pop-up menu of blah styler
blah blah blah blah blah
does that then become a restriction or
is that then an appearance
thing the
what i'm saying yeah yeah the if i
understand correctly the appearance
option
only controls the appearance of the
control not the underlying date object
that's being controlled i don't care
this this thing here
look look you can't have the right hand
side
both be a
a thing that selects what values are
allowed
and a thing that determines what kind of
control comes up
do you see what i'm saying am i being
confused nick do you understand this
yeah i mean i think i'm not as familiar
with the aspect of how appearance is
used in other controls but it does seem
no i i agree i i i agree
um uh
so yeah the i mean the interesting thing
is that uh uh you know
my my first uh thought is to compare
this to something like locator but you
know in locator there's no
there's no necessarily visual feedback
about the the kind of constraint that
you're imposing where
in this case you probably want some sort
of visual
feedback what is that what is the
mechanism for constraints in locator
well it's it's mostly uh it's mostly
your dynamic function
um uh that
you know you uh you know you do
something like a you know
say apply a round or sine and cosine to
keep it on a circle or something like
that
um um the
but uh uh and you could certainly do
that here
but it would just be confusing if it
were like well
the date is there but i'm trying to
click on it and it won't let me click on
it
uh what you probably want to do is if a
particular date shouldn't be selected
you probably want to gray the date out
lay in the calendar view for example
right but in particular
we this notion of
okay so one possibility is a date
selection function
that basically says is this date a
possible date
yeah another one is you know
pick tuesdays and thursdays you know
it's affirmatively picking things
now we have a mechanism don't we at
least under development
for specifying groups of dates is that
correct
well at that interval could specify that
but i i'm looking at this perhaps this
is not so different so the previous case
says
uh say calendar goes to pop-up menu
and this is also a pop-up menu in both
cases it's acting as a function it's
just that in the previous case we need
we didn't need the hash and here we do
need the hash
well but the pop-up menu wait a minute
the issue is
right so you were complaining that
before i mean in the
just a bit above there is calendar goes
to pop-up menu yep
which seems like it's just saying pop-up
menu but perhaps pop-up menu is being
used there as a function oh no no i
agree it's being used as a function but
the point is what is it a function of
what's it doing
so pop-up menu there is a thing that
says
put the pop-up menu in the position
where you're selecting a year
it's not saying make me an array of
years
and label them you know well i mean
okay what is this control this thing
here
what is that because that's the place
where you're going to be you know
have selection allow okay in a pop-up
menu
there is to my knowledge no way of
saying here's a pop-up menu
but some of its entries are not allowed
to be selected
or is there a way to do that i mean i
mean we might just remove those entries
well i understand that i understand one
could remove them or for clarity one
could gray them out
i mean if there are no available dates
in march
um i application i it is
in principle possible to have uh
uh a grayed out pop-up menu that that
does nothing when you select it i mean
it's
it's just it's a little bit of hackery
behind the scenes but it is possible
i think for calendars it makes more
sense to have things grayed out
than to have a missing month yeah i
think it's very well
well and and and and i think you know
the more i think about this i mean this
makes sense if we have you know a
completely
independent date restriction
function or whatever you call it um then
the implications of that date
restriction function
can be automatically applied to
all of our built-in uh date center
appearances now if you
build your you know a completely custom
view
of course you're on your own but if you
use anything that kind of
we are auto populating then we'll help
you out
by grains you shouldn't use date setter
it doesn't give you anything if you if
it's completely custom view
well well yeah i mean you you might uh
uh oh you might do something like
you know use an input field to enter
something and then
we can't give you any signals in an
input field about
you know right what month okay so what
is the potential date selection function
because i mean
but but what you would have to do in
that case is as you render
any particular view so if i jump from
march to april for example
as then you'd have to run through for
every different date in april
you have to run through the date
selection function and see is it grayed
out or not
which i think is reasonable yeah i don't
think it's unreasonable
now here there is for example a way of
restricting
per year so it so
i mean we could use date select with a
criteria with an operator form and that
would be super general
it can be applied to any date but
but the advantage here is that you can
immediately say i don't want
years or i only want years of 221
without having to go through the 365 of
them
i'm sorry what what's the advantage i'm
sorry i'm confused that this case here
so this is you can only reach these
things because they're the only ones
that are in the
control right what i'm saying is that
imagine that you
want to select i don't know the second
half of
all year in that range so
it may be easy to say yes i want from
1990
to 2000 and months i went for 7 to 12.
that i don't see why that factoring is
useful i mean look
i might want only leap year only
non-leap years
right okay and um
okay so there are two ways to
not be able to select a date one
because the controls just let don't you
get let you get there from here
and two because it's grayed out within
the things which are being shown by the
controls
and and and i would suggest maybe those
are separate
things i mean there might be there there
might be
uh particularly for years there might be
you know
uh a range specification that
you know oh only show years from
2019 to 2029 um
well that's what the restricted
mechanism would would suggest
yeah you could wrap restricted around
the year potentially i don't know if
that's an abuse of
that syntax and similarly you could wrap
restricts around the month although it's
less likely to be useful
yeah i i don't know how uh how
potentially uh pathological the
restricted syntax
gets i i'm not familiar with it it's
i hope it's if it's not too pathological
i'll go along with it but
you know um no it's very hacky i mean
it's basically a
a here are specific kinds of
restrictions which are useful for
particular kinds of data types
yeah but but in terms of date selection
and and someone pointed this out
in the uh in the comments that uh uh
i mean you know you might want to do any
kind of date selection you might want to
you might just have a list of
10 dates and you want it to be you know
only
to be able to select from those 10 dates
and i think you know having a calendar
where you could kind of navigate
anywhere but only see those 10 dates
light up
is a perfectly reasonable thing yeah i
agree
i i think there's there's another case
unfortunately which is
um you know i can imagine both
blackout dates and waitlist dates
that is preferred
you know somehow indicating preference
preferred dates
right this is these are the possible
dates you can take your vacation to
uh null island or something and um
uh these are you know
this is the um i don't know the next
available or the
or the the the dates where there's a
special discount available
or something that making sense so in
other words
that's a decoration that is a styling
so to speak of the calendar that goes
beyond just the blackout thing
does that make sense to people it's just
like you know we've got styling
of um you know data set and things like
that
styling of a calendar display and by the
way i would like to make the following
comment
this display of a calendar in which you
are selecting a particular day
you know you should be able to get this
out as a pure piece of output just like
you can
you know for example i could imagine a
data set where
you would want these kinds of displays
so so my claim is that date format
should have a mechanism to have a a
calendar-like
display where a single date or date
interval
is highlighted in in something like this
does that make sense
yeah i think the case for data interval
is potentially more complicated
but i think yeah and to be yeah
and and to be clear the uh this also was
you know one of the questions that came
up in the live stream uh
the uh we're purposely avoiding
date interval for this review because
date interval
brings in a lot more issues than
just uh you know picking a date or
picking a time uh
it's on our list uh kevin has the
beginnings of something but it has some
very clear shortcomings that are
make it not ready to review yet you mean
selecting a range of dates for example
yes or you know i i mean very
very usually selecting uh yeah something
that's you know a beginning and an
end you know uh okay so i've got another
another point here
just like we have um timeline plot
shouldn't we have a calendar plot
which is essentially like what i would
see in my uh you know online calendar
it has times blocked off and things like
this
so in other words you could imagine if
we if we had a calendar
format for date object then it seems
like
calendar plot would be a
not crazy extension to that
right but i mean calendar plot means
you've got
this plot this thing here and i'm
coloring
the every day by how what the
temperature was on that day
that type of thing it's a form of visual
display that i can imagine being quite
useful
and particularly in the case of times
when you have time intervals
you know being able to i would love to
be able to take my
you know for example you know like like
take my calendar for the last year
and um uh you know just color code how
many meetings i had per day
and display it as a calendar array as an
array of months
by the way you absolutely need a version
of this view
that is i mean you know i would have
thought you need a version of this view
and arguably you should even have that
as a as a
sort of a a a um
an interactive pull down you know week
month day
type thing or you know month
month week day year month weekday
right so in other words just like you
know any old average online calendar
lets you get to a point where you know
let's say i wanted to fill something in
i wanted to select the time you know 8
15 a.m
on the 19th see what i'm saying
i would like to be able to drill down in
this thing and get to that
so more of the features along the lines
of a true calendar app
i would think so why not i mean because
that's what
okay look there are two different things
there's
you know what will this be used for this
will be used
i mean one could use it as a calendar
one could use it you know
i don't know where um
like for instance you know i would think
on the web
it's like uh you know you want to set up
office hours for
in our at our um you know summer school
okay go to this web you know
web api and select the hour you want
and it's already been it is it's back
end has already blacked out
the things that are no longer available
do you get what i'm saying and and for
example in that case
you can imagine and this is where the
state selection function is a little bit
trickier because
you know i can say i'm available 9 30 to
10 30
p.m on these days
and you know specific time it could be 9
27
p.m to 9 32 p.m or something
you don't know what it's not going to be
something where you can just go through
and run
through and say you know is this a day
accepted or rejected type thing
so i'm saying i don't think it's going
to work to have in other words i think
it's a little bit less trivial i don't
immediately see how to do it
this concept of of blackout
selection as opposed to affirmatively
saying
these are the allowed regions now
possibly it can be done with
inequalities
that may be the right way to do it nick
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah i mean the immediate example i
thought of is you know you're trying to
book your vacation like you said and you
can't book in the past there may be some
dates the hotel isn't
available i know but those are day wise
yeah i'm talking about the thing where
where i'm available from 9 25 p.m
to 9 45 p.m right
you know i mean i mean maybe there are
other applications
where where this makes more sense but
i've i've never
seen a thing that you know that actually
stops you from making
you know such allocations in your
calendar it only
kind of makes it clear that there's a
potential conflict but i've never seen
anything that
you know literally is like no you can't
you know
i think
i don't know i seem to remember like
like when i was booking my my um uh
covert vaccine thing i'm pretty sure the
app
there was um you know it's like these
times are available
the other ones are not
yeah but you're not selecting a uh well
uh
i'm not saying well sorry yeah i'm i'm
thinking about
i'm thinking about a range of times
which actually i shouldn't be thinking
about
right because that's a different
selected times
um
are you not used to seeing like a
calendar side by side with something
that has a
finer granularity so like if you've
selected a day then you can see to the
side
the calendar is still present but you
can then see
you know in the in the calendar in the
whatever zimbra whatever it is calendar
or ical
calendar that that i normally use it's
like
you know you can select their the
overall granularity
yeah what keep in mind that this
version of the control i mean this is
you know i just said we're not talking
about
uh interval selection uh the
you know this version the control
literally just
uh allows you to choose you know one
time
only not a time plus uh
you know you know that covers the next
15 minute block or something like that
that's
you know i understand but sandra is
pointing out on a
live stream that you know having a today
button is important
otherwise you get lost in the future
lost certainly
yeah um
but again those are things that should
be settable in the appearance setting
but have some default
yeah see i can imagine that a view of
this
in which you're just in which instead of
you know the first view is just the year
2021
you've got the months here and you just
click the month in an array
and then you go down to the month and
you've drilled down to this you might
click the day
except that that is a conflict for the
click operation
for is it selection or is it drill down
see what i'm saying
[Music]
so you're describing a view that is uh
very uh click focused you start at the
grant the highest level granularity and
you just drill down as you go
well i'm not sure that's the right thing
is that because you've got to be able to
have click to select
perhaps you can select and there is a
button that says go go inside or
something
possibly or a raft that comes up when
when that happens
um
you select and there's a there's some
kind of uh
you know raft pop-down thing that says
drill down or something like the words
drill down aren't the right words
um
i'm not really sure there's a
standardized thing that you
[Music]
you know would want to have in that sort
of drill down i mean there are so many
different ways one might want to go well
it's showing you the time the date the
times right
well well not necessarily
uh you know it it it might you know if
it's a
you know if it's an alarm then it might
show you
uh uh a clock widget
uh you know to to set the time if it's
uh
uh if it's a set of flights then it
might give you just give you
five flights that happen to be at
specific times
um yeah that's a good point uh would you
mind if i shared my screen briefly
go ahead okay
um one second just one second okay
ah this isn't easy to arrange for a
particular reason
what what do you have do you can you see
i have a yeah i have a notebook that you
could evaluate how do i send that to you
send me email okay
so feel free to continue the discussion
i'll get an email to you shortly
okay um
okay yes ethan is asking about the cloud
this absolutely has to work in the cloud
sure i'm sure now amber was asking make
it expandable to full calendar view i'm
not
quite sure what uh maybe
maybe the they're referring to
here the ability to do like a 12-month
calendar
right and uh
which i think having a range of things
you know it's you know i mean not just a
12-month calendar but you know a
two-month calendar is useful too
um you know i very frequently see
two-month calendars when i'm due
when i'm doing uh travel planning for
example
right she's commenting here uh use a
flatter design without gradients yeah
yeah yeah
um controls should only appear on hover
or add a control on a circle to allow
the user to change values
not quite sure what you mean these
controls up here
or maybe in the date object type setting
to have it look like a string until you
hover over
the particular granularity
yes yeah well i think that's reasonable
i mean
i think that um uh i agree that this is
pretty heavyweight
does christina want to comment on that
nope okay all right
so go ahead and evaluate the entire
notebook that i sent you
and the example is actually at the
bottom of the notebook
it only is pink boxing right now because
the definitions aren't there yet
the example in uh still positively pink
like interesting so you evaluate
input 25 again see what happens
okay so now it's a clickable thing
so this is a very click forward version
of the interface so you can cycle grids
of dates and as you click it
automatically goes down to the next
granularity
but you always have the option to go
backwards and this is just a little how
do i get back
uh at this point you can click the year
in the upper left corner to go back to
year
or you can click the upper center i got
two versions
it's because i made changes to the
calendar appearance in preparation for
the live stream that kind of got burned
in here
it would normally have just been the day
calendar portion this this part here
yes you can either cancel the selection
you've currently made or go back to a
different granularity oh this is quite
nice
and that seems quite nice to me
um
the in this case the changes you make
don't get applied to the underlying
symbol
um until you've completed your selection
so all the way down
no no but but how do what if i wanted
what if i want to select the whole year
2023
uh this isn't this is still focused on
day granularity
that's not the right thing well
yeah i mean you can make a control for
year granularity but that's
not what this control is doing right but
the question is
okay so the issue is is it the case so
like in a calendar app
it's always time blocks well no you can
always have a whole day event
right in a calendar
but there's a notion of a whole day
event that's probably not a notion of a
whole week event
well but once again keep in mind that
we're not
we're not selecting intervals here you
know the result is going to be a date
object it's no i i really
realize that i realize that but i'm just
saying that that
you're saying you have to preemptively
decide this is going to be a year
selection or a month selection
as opposed to deciding that at the
moment you know there's no particularly
good reason that i can see
why this shouldn't allow you by this
interface shouldn't allow you to decide
what granularity level it is
i mean it doesn't seem to me like
something that would be
that useful if anything it seems to me
like it would be more likely to generate
user bugs you know in terms of you know
people writing code that
didn't expected date object that only
had specified a year
yeah okay fair enough well i like this
this
basic setup of this this kind of drill
down i mean
in although i mean look of really common
cases
today is set so to speak
now you're going to set something by the
way
yes i mean so a pretty common thing is a
future only calendar
yeah or a past only calendar
yeah for birthdays or something
why would that be passed on oh you mean
for dates above yeah
yeah um
right so is there a mechanism for
specifying past only a future only
not currently i mean i you know i think
that comes down to this date restriction
mechanism that we've been talking about
um well but it's a little bit i mean
probably we should have future
past um sure yeah
yeah that i mean uh yes it would make
sense to
have some maybe some string selectors
which which do
really common scenarios um and
then it's you know except an arbitrary
function for you know basically
you know saying up or down for a given
dates
okay but but i think a pretty common
case will be here are the possible dates
these are the possible
you know uh trips to null island
or whatever it is um
so being able to give a list of those
and say select which one of these you
want
i agree that seems reasonable
there's also our clinic is closed on
thursdays type thing
right you know removal thursdays
yeah um
which is more like a an actual boolean
computation so to speak
presumably done on the fly so in other
words whatever is being displayed
you ask of the elements that are being
displayed
um now you know clearly there's a
there's a
you know it could be the case that
you're still allowed the month of july
has some blackout times but something in
july is still allowed
so you still leave july in the well
and and and and similarly if you know
you have a discrete list of dates
and you know those dates contain uh
you know include uh july and september
but not august uh then
i think you should still display you
know
august it would be confusing it would be
like i think you should gray it out
though i think you should display it
fully grade yeah
yes because that way otherwise you're
going and
you know you know opening the little
doors and saying is there anything
behind this door and that's really
annoying
yeah okay so just again this calendar
plot concept
presumably that can work like timeline
plot
so whatever formats there are here and i
could also imagine a calendar plot
that is uh explorable
that is there is a value for every date
whatever it is there's a there's a
you know i can imagine that i want to
uh sort of plot my busyness level as a
function of time
for the last 10 years and i'm only going
to see
a particular month at a time you get
what i'm saying
but i can go and select other things
right that makes sense so it's like a
tab view or something
obviously didn't roger have some
discussion about that at one point or
another
so yes with brett we have discussed the
possibility of having some visualization
for calendars and i think he has
explored in the past about it
okay but i'm saying i think that should
merge with what we're doing here
all right what other things do we make
need to make well certainly
it would be nice to have a unified
graphic design i think
uh definitely so i'm not reinventing the
wheel which does support the notion of
controls only on hover in other words
given that you know it's controllable
given that you know this is a calendar
selector there's no reason to have
you know front and center um
uh
you know great big arrowy things
because you kind of know in modern times
this is going to be selectable
uh i'm somewhere in the middle
i i agree it doesn't need to be quote
great big arrowy things but uh
uh but there are cases where people get
confused because
there's nothing you know
no i know i've been confused by that oh
is this selectable i had no idea
yeah i think we could find like a
balance somehow
yeah fine maybe yeah all right
i'm gonna have to disappear in a few
minutes um so what else
uh well let's take a look at time setter
real quick
time setter is actually simpler
i i know but it's simpler but that's
because you haven't dealt with intervals
which is the main thing of interest for
time setter
dandy i mean i don't know what time zone
it wants to display by default all those
kinds of things presumably it has the
same time zone options as date object
yeah the reason it's not displaying time
zone is i didn't
basically make a control for it so i
just took it out of the display
for the time being um
once again you'll probably want to look
under appearance
hold on one second
now the contribution to time setter
that's different from date center is
this uh
clock appearance which is a this analog
clock
you mean you can move the hands around
or not yes
all the hands yep yeah try it
cool but you can't do that on on unlike
the apple can you or is that one of
these cases where i didn't know you
could control something
yeah well well i i i i use i use android
but yes
it's this is exactly you can wind it to
your heart's content
example of a case where i would have no
idea that you could do yeah there are a
couple of details that are different
from the way kevin's implemented it
which you've been going back and forth
in
terms of what you see on cell phones but
yeah yeah this this
this works on this is very much a cell
phone like thing
i had no idea all these years
okay fine it's a comment from ethan that
he thinks
timeline plot is old and needs love i
don't know this is probably the wrong
team to talk
to about that um be interesting to get
specific comments about things that
seem to be sort of long in the tooth
um the details about this interface
right now is that as you mouse down and
drag
you actually get the uh specific ticks
but once you let go it snaps to what the
analog clock yeah
yeah move the move the minute hand to
11.
uh and then uh try dragging
the hour hand uh and
and let go
uh well it's it was because it's it's
it's you know
like 655 but of course
655 has the hour hand nearly pointing to
seven
oh um gosh which is unbelievably
confusing
yeah well why don't the detents why
aren't the detents dynamic
um i mean it's uh
uh that just seems crazy to me that's
just
it was a choice for sure
it may not be the right choice which is
why we're
i think that the tents should be dynamic
yeah i think whatever you whatever you
set this to
that's what should determine where the
detents go
right so that will be completely correct
because it's at the top of the hour
and this would be you know go to halfway
just so because you can see that hour
hand moving i mean it's obvious
that then the thing is so so so the way
that android
deals with this and i don't remember how
ios deals with it maybe someone else
knows here but the way that android
deals with it
is it only shows one hand at a time
um so you know it shows you that is say
like you know uh 315 you know it will
it will highlight the three and then the
hand is the hour hand or highlight the
15
and the hand is the minute hand guys i
have to go so okay
um all right this was a great start
i had not realized you know of course
we're fairly early in the development
cycle here
so we will get several more chances to
go through this but i think this was a
yes
reduction here okay looks pretty nice
okay thank you all right so uh
thanks to folks on the live stream for
their comments and
see